Well, welcome here in this
talk, we are going to try to show you
what the irons behind the
synchronicity of javascript are. They are
concepts that help us understand a
little about how we are programming, how
everything is working behind and it is never
bad to learn the things that, well,  They
don't come with the firmware included,
so I'm excited that you
both understand some of the things below, such
as data structure or
other things. You also have to understand
how the entire language ecosystem works,
so we're going to look at different
topics.  one in what would be the call bugs
which is how things were handled with
all the ways that the browser has the
promises that it is a new way to
be able to keep track of everything that
is happening the integrators a new
way to have the  usual looks that
before were done in a strict way that
you said how the machine had to go step by step
to be able to grab that
information from the data structure
the generators which is a new part
of keys that tells you that now you can
have paw saber functions
the  a thing away method that gives us a
little more readability of how we are
doing all the synchronicity of
our program and at the end we are going to
give a conclusion of when to use each
one and what is good for each part
but to be able to start we are going to see that
They would be the approach of the call bugs
seeing it from an asynchronous point
and in order to understand this we are going to see
how the javascript ecosystem works.
javascript only has 3 speaking
only of the execution because there
may already be several that have a service
worker that has three others  but here
we are focusing purely on the
execution of our browser code
and this is going to be executed without clearly meaning
that we are going to go line
by line seeing what can be
run ignoring comments and other
annotations and that part is going to  having to
finish
the entire function is going to have to finish to be able to continue to
the next line, what this gives us to
understand is that it has a very
complex behavior that means I am not going
to move on to another part of the code until
I can complete it.  This piece that
I am executing, what if someone
who has not used javascript is going to say
is that then if I have to complete
everything then I am going to complete the
screen, the user is not going to be able to
interact with it when he goes to grab
his credentials everything is going to  It's going to be chaos and there's
not going to be a good user experience
but then what's going on
if you really have to have to
complete everything in one
place because like the same thing we
always said we're going to have to wait for some
a server because we are
on the side of the brou if we need to grab
all the information that has already been
perceived in that case we have something
called the college tag
memory and bubble environment and the thread
of execution the thread of execution is the
that is going to be reading all the lines
of code that we have in
the memory variable bar méndez, how is it going to
play the different scouts that we
are going to put in our programs and
alcohol, this is all the functions
that are going to accumulate to be able to
run  Apart from this, we only have
keys that we have, other than the
browser paths, these give us access to
the timers that have the document and a
whole infinity of events that
we can use but that are not in themselves
the ones that usually happen to me.  It is a package
of that same browser extension so
that we can use it as if it
were the native Javascript language.
Apart from that, we have the event loop.
All those who have not heard what
this means. It is a program that is
executed that sees what part.
asynchronous or what pending functions
have to be executed if and only if none of the
chronless code has been finished,
then in this way we can see
a way to see the code here I
gave you a small example of code in
which we are going to create a  function
called prince load and we are going to
send them to a time out this s time out is
the phase of what we had told you about
the sep already from the browser it is not
only available in the
javascript ecosystem this is an idea  that they give us
and what this trip does is send that
function that we have to a queue
and it will be executed when the
condition that a thousand mini seconds have passed is met,
this gives us to understand that it
is not going to be exactly the same
milliseconds.  When it is going to be called,
but at 1000 milliseconds, it will be
sent to the queue so that when the
event loops and that queue, if something is
available and there is no code without a
chrono running, it can be sent to the call
stack to be able to execute like this.  This
way, if we go from line 1
to 8 we will see that the only code
without chrono that is not using the bald,
which is on line 8, is doing
a with only that it will send it
directly to the call stack and print  the
end hello and then it will print
line 6 and line 5
and nothing more to clarify that what is
happening this is for all the gifts that
when we click
this event is also happening without timing the
event will be checking  every time
the entire code without chrono has been completed,
not before or after, therefore
all the time is to be solved
immediately they will have to wait
for all the code 5 peace without chrono
to pass
and this one I
lost them they
keep seeing you
and what I'm showing you here is going to
be more or less how
the scoop that we
said is going to be grabbed, that's going to be the memory heap with
the hosting, that would be a
separate topic, we're going to see what they're going to be.
the different scope and baviera cando
the memory in your program
with this we are going to see how
the kovacs will work now since
we have understood that the negative part
is that we do not have any tracking of
what is the status of that function that
we pass to it.  to be
completely the execution is going to be
totally of the way that we
are using to execute the not
on our side that does not give us problems
of inversion of control so there
are these new things that are called
promises I say new because
really  They have been there for many years
but
it is the next thing that came out for the
curves and the promises are now on our
side and you see that a way to be able to
follow what is the status of the function
that we sent you would be pendín
it would be verse it would be that  It was a mistake
and that way we can
counteract what is happening
by doing one. Here we are also going to
pass it a type of col bucks but now
we have a cleaner way of how
we are going to do it since we have a function
called come  What it allows us to
do is send it an array of
functions of what are going to be the
possible solutions of everything that is going
to happen when that function is resolved and
a catch property that also
allows us to add everything that would be the
errors.
It's like adding it, it's not
exactly when it runs, it's going to go to
the IES function or execute it, if it's not
a reference of what functions we want to
execute when this has happened,
to be able to understand a little bit what's
happening, we're going to use it with the face
that  It is a promise that already comes in
browsers commonly and what it does is
grab an x ​​h x hr to any
place and grab the information
back in this way we will be
able to say give me this information and I
will tell you what you are going to do  to do
when you complete with a
callback function either in a
correct or error state
and
just loads the next page you win
when we call a promise
we will have the value which is what
will return to us when it is already  has fulfilled
and on 11 the field that they are going to make the
col bucks arrangement that we
sent with the point come to that promise
and every time the value changes from share
and the fine to something it is that
anfield arrangement they are called every  one if nothing
else we have once because we made the
point that only that function is going to be called
and if you realize this way
to handle errors is a little
cleaner because we only have to
add the functions to the catch point and
not  We have to do any
ugly thing like we said before in I say we don't have to
pass the callback tree arrangement
which is Iranian giving all
the functions until it already looks like
a pyramid so this gives us a
little more eligibility for that part
Now we are going to analyze what the entire
execution of this part would be like, combining it
with what we saw previously about the call
bucks. If we see from line 1 and
line 2, we are creating a function in
which it will be one that prints what
we want.  let's go and the second one that
always prints hello
we go to the third line and there we
are going to add a call to the timer
white that is going to create that jumping
directly as we know it is an
asynchronous function so we are going to send it to the
bucket of asynchronous things as we already know
directly fulfilled, it happens so that
when there is no longer any code without
chrono, we are going to run it,
then we move on to a function that is going
to completely block the train.
This means that it is going to be something very
complex that is going to involve many calculations that are
not synchronous and will not work.  to be an
infinite loop of 1,8000
recursion, it is only going to block for 5
milliseconds. Then we are going to move on to
assigning a promise to the
fitur variable of ira.
As we remember, we need to add a
callback to that promise so that when
we receive  the return value
can act with that value that is why
we add that vent
print point so that when we receive
that strip we can print it in the
console as it is an asynchronous function
also until it is resolved we will be
able to add it to the  queue we are going to say
that it is a somewhat stable server
expert we are going to treat ourselves as a
second in receiving that response
then we have the same as when
we directly resolved a timer with a
zero we are going to be able to resolve a promise
with point ruiz or directly and then
add the  handler that it will have
when it is resolved here, how we put the
point of the sun and the one in parentheses
that we will receive that test
value is the one that will be printed in
our print function and since it is
asynchronous, it will not be  go directly to the
college taxi did not send it we send it to the
club
again we are going to block it on 3 for 5
milliseconds and in that 5 milliseconds that we are
going to block the function that we
had set that was going to take a
second it will be fulfilled and  We are going to
send it again to the club because it has already passed
its condition to be added.
Lastly, we have something without a timer that
can be executed directly, so
it will go directly to the callback to the
college tag and we will see in the console
our first message, which will be
final
now we are going to see this little picture here
that is going to be our
our console to see how
things are going to happen
seeing things as if we were with the
brush or we see that the prince is going to
print it until the end but it was the
first that was added to the queue this is
a bit strange behavior since
we specifically told it that it
was going to be the first thing that was going to be
resolved but it was resolved until the end
because it will be this is exactly because
there are two types of cues one q  It is
directly for all the promises and
the other is for the call bucks, this
allows us to say that all the promises that I
am going to resolve are going to have a
higher priority than all the curves that I am going to
have, therefore, if you remember, we
made the  first one that went to the
normal script and all the promises went to
the one with the highest priority and that's why
they were printed before
so what will be the development of the
event in this of our
javascript applications is that I will always try
to run  the main network that will be all
the code without chrono all the
asynchronous code will try to send it until
a condition exists that can
add it to the cues if I have already finished reading
all my code without chrono I will see what is
in the  micro is the one with the
promises and see if there is something that can be
added if there is nothing that can be
added now I check the cv of the call
bucks and if there is something there that we cannot
add cause tag we put it and if they
are already there  those two empty cue we finish the
program
that is the beehive that
all javascript applications commonly have
with that we have already completed how what is
happening and we are going to
analyze how the a5 weight was created to
have greater readability from
Developers
first have to see what
integrators are and what generators are
for all those who do not know a
bunk door is a way of a new
way of receiving information from a
data structure in which instead of
us going and with  an index and a
counter that says 'I'm going element by
element grabbing all the information,
I'm going to tell you, give me my information
when I need it,
this is all my information is going to be on
with a protocol that is very
established that has to be  a method
called next and what this method is going
to return is a valium and a complete if
the value has if when it fulfills it has something you
will no longer be able to continue calling anything
from the next and it is always going to
return whatever it is going to  have until
the value is a the file complete is going to
be true
therefore here is the way that
we are going to create that integrator
from scratch
this is using something called the
cluster for all those who do not know
what it is it is all  the functions that
return another function that persists a
state that we have is the
a little easier way that I have been able to
find it but since it is a somewhat
complex topic everyone is going to have their own
definition so it
can be developed a little more for
itself as very  He pulled it flat that is
what I could tell you
so here what we are going to persist
is the variable and
that index that we have in our king is going to increase and
every time we say return
next is only what we are going
to have  as the next element
next element then if you notice it
's not like give me all the elements and
apply this function but every time
I want it gives me it gives me it's a piece of
that data structure another bit
another bit of another bit that's
how we go  to try to
implement all seven videos
normally they already come built with the
language in the most common structures
such as objects and arrays so we
don't have to worry but so
you can understand this is how it is
working
and the generators is another thing that
helps us  to create paw saber functions
so here all you have to do
to be able to create this
function is put the little
star sign that appears there
and use a reserved word to
say here I need what pause is the
function return to whoever is delivering
and the next time you
call me with next here we are going to follow
the execution contact then and we are going
to analyze how what
would happen when we
read all this code how we have a
function declaration all that code
It is encapsulated in a variable
called great low
to be able to create our generator
we have to call that function
when we call it we are going to
have the iter protocol which
means that every time we
give next we are going to search until the
next part in which we
have to pause and exit the
execution context then we start
when we declare return exactly and
create that kind of function then there
we can the first way we can
access the function code is
by calling next on the next line
where we have  the next point we are going to
enter the execution context of
create web where we are going to see that
a variable called name is created with a
value of 10 then we create a variable
of new 1 that we call and there we
directly exit the
execution context but it  We give the
num variable to whoever was using it, for
example, element 1 that we
declared with cost 1 in the penultimate
line of the code is the one that will receive
that 10 that we declared in
our generation
but in line number 3 it is not  has
assigned nothing because it left the
execution context, therefore
when we call it in the last
line the point next with a value of 2,
the new will not be assigned with the
number 2 that we assigned it
because now it returns to the context of
execution that we already had and can now
assign the value from right to left,
therefore the next time we
go out here the 5-1 guide is going to give us
a value of 7 that will be assigned to
element number 2, this is a  a little
complex if you have not understood well how
the pause bless functions work, it is
very worth it to understand it well
when you leave the context of
executions and how to give it
variables again to be able to have all
this new way of having
functions paw sabers
but look what it is for me in a
white farm
then that is when we can say what
would happen if I said wait until
I already have a response from our
server and then continue with
your function this is the concept behind
the wait yes tape  Notice here we are going to
have a function that is going to be return
expelled in which we are going to
call it next when we receive the
information from our back-end and there in
our type iron which is the project we
are going to exit it from the context of  execution
returning the promise of grabbing the ipi
eyeos ussr so to understand a
little better we go to the first
declaration of the constant which is the
expand version
in which we are going to execute our
greater
as we are just executing it
we need to use the net
es function to be able to enter  to the
execution context of that function and wait for it to
complete
now that in the second line where
we create the consell we are going to have the
future of ira
now we are going to call the next point that
already gives us access to the
execution context and users as  We have a
users guide and we are going to return it to future
day and the value of the promise is assigned to
fitur de ira to be able to have one to
be able to assign a callback as we
had seen the promises the last
line is a little complex but it is
because they have  We need to understand how
the generator worked. If you remember, it
had an integrator pattern in which
we return a value and a
complete. How we want to add a
callback to the promise, then we are going to
have to access it through that
credit protocol through the point
valid.  so in the end what we are
telling you is fitur to go to the point
okay point to grab that information
that we have and when you already receive this
then continue with the function that we do not
have that prints the with only
our generator
that would be the whole concept behind
asinca way of how they are working and
if you look at these eight lines that look
very complex, they have reduced it to just that
if you want to use this
behavior you put a prefix to your
function that says like this and
anywhere you want to wait as if  If it were
code without chrono, you just
put a white on it, but you have to be
very clear that it is not happening when
if it were code without chrono,
all this is happening behind the scenes and that is why we have
synchronous readability for an
asynchronous execution
and with that we give  our
little talk on how
synchronicity works in javascript is over